so Steven Spielberg has a new movie
coming out in November it's called
Lincoln you've probably seen the
pictures or the trailer it's going to be
great right I mean it's one of the
historical epics I start to think that
Spielberg now makes three different
kinds of movies right he makes these
historical epics that he really cares
about he makes sort of a Lincoln or a
Schindler's List right as the classic
example and he makes the the kind of
mawkish emotional ones so warhorse right
which I didn't think was very good
although you know Spielberg really knows
how to point a camera so it look great
and then he makes the science fiction
movies right so Lincoln coming out is
made me think of something that's been
bothering me about Spielberg science
fiction for years I came to Steven
Spielberg movies the same way people of
my age do I guess what through jaws and
Close Encounters right Close Encounters
if you have not seen it in decades is an
amazing movie it's fantastic right I
mean it's just suspenseful every beat
works it goes on forever and you wish it
was even longer I mean that's why you
could release that special edition like
give us more of this movie the the
relations between the mom who loses her
kid to the aliens is incredible and
Richard Dreyfuss is great right um
playing this guy who's kind of on the
ground in the midst of a first-contact
situation but of course you can also
read Close Encounters in a very
different metaphoric way and this is why
science fiction is so terrific right
because it's really kind of secretly
about the dissolution of a family this
guy Richard Dreyfuss is sort of getting
dissipated he he gives in his own
obsessions and leaves his family he
leaves his wife leaves Teri Garr which
is like crazy talk because you don't
leave Teri Garr and kids and goes off
because he goes kind of nuts and even
though he's validated at the end right
it turns out that he wasn't nuts there
really were aliens coming the movie
still exists on this metaphoric plane so
you can have the the textual one of like
oh it's aliens and their science fiction
and also the subtextual one of like
where's daddy going right of trying to
explain in the 70s where these daddies
with and of course Spielberg was always
working on kind of father issues it is
science fiction especially right like
where's the dad in ET it's just not
there good science fiction always does
this right you think about the first
couple of seasons of buffy the vampire
my favorite TV shows of all time and of
course the reason Buffy works is that in
addition to being this great paranormal
adventure it also might all kind of be
happening in Buffy's head in a weird way
I don't mean that she's crazy and I said
some of the same thing in an earlier
observation deck episode of about piece
of the southern wild right where you
don't have to know really whether the
the science fiction is literal or
metaphorical evel's it's supposed to
that's part of the fun now let's jump
forward a few decades to another
Spielberg science fiction movie war of
the worlds right which could have been
great and was pitched as you know what
it would be like to be in the middle of
an alien invasion but not be like the
scientist in charge which is who the
hero was in the George pal 1950s for the
world's right but just be a guy on the
ground surrounded by this stuff and
again it's a father in disrepair right
the main character is a as a father
who's not connected with his family
anymore he's supposed to be kind of a
schlub II New Jersey dude who isn't in
touch with his kids but this time
instead of Richard Dreyfuss Gilbert
casts Tom Cruise now when you cast Tom
Cruise in a movie you get Tom Cruise and
I actually like him um he can be great
and when he's playing Tom Cruise you
know when when the movies kind of do
this thing where it's like he's hosting
the Oscars whenever he makes an
appearance the movie kind of stops for a
second goes ladies and gentlemen mr. Tom
Cruise and he comes in and he does Tom
Cruise stuff which is great but in War
of the Worlds the emotional subtext was
supposed to be about a father
reconnecting with his family through
trauma right and instead you get Tom
Cruise you know Tom cruising around
right he throws a grenade into a Martian
tripod or something he actually does
become the hero so imagine if Steven
Spielberg still cast movies the way he
used to in the 70s and I'm not the first
person to say this actually bill wasiq
my colleague my was talking about this
earlier too with the metaphor thing but
imagine if instead of casting Tom Cruise
he'd cast let's say Philip Seymour
Hoffman as the hero in more of the world
now he's got to move the master it's
going to be artistic and amazing but
imagine if the father in war of the
worlds had been slubby right it
mentioned the father more the world's
had been someone who you didn't see as
an action hero it would restore the
metaphor Steven Spielberg is a guy who
seriously knows how to point a camera
but Lincoln reminds me that I wish that
he spent as much time to
a on the emotional core of the science
fiction as he does on historical epics
you